Hilary Clinton of course not feeling
well and here's the interesting thing
Donald Trump is being nice about it
that's right Donald Trump said he wishes
Hillary Clinton a speedy recovery from
her pneumonia yeah that's what he said
that's true sorry yeah yeah he said
get well soon you shrill line crook now
this is crazy some conspiracy theorists
and there are a lot of them out there is
probably something here tonight some
conspiracy theorists are claiming that
Hillary Clinton is so sick she that
she's been using a body double yeah when
Bill Clinton heard about he said man I
wish
let the auditions commence
[Applause]
maybe maybe after Hillary Clinton's
health scare yesterday Donald Trump has
said he will release his medical records
and he said he's expecting some quote
very large numbers yeah Trump said I'm
going to show you a prostate ditch you
to you cholesterol a 7,000 yeah it's
pretty yeah half the time in medicine
the big number is a very bad news yes
all the numbers are huge blood pressure
huge people are still talking about
Hillary Clinton dissing Trump supporters
several days ago yeah Hillary Clinton
called 50% of Trump supporters a quote
basket of deplorable and now she says
she regrets it yeah she feels that
instead of basket she should have said
shitload
[Applause]
a new report came out shows that Donald
Trump's charity once bought a football
helmet autographed by Tim Tebow yeah
yeah that explains Trump's first
campaign slogan make America a garage
full of worthless sports memorabilia
yeah why would they buy that I don't
know buying a Conan headshot I'm a great
an ass great athlete North Korea has
been trying to increase tourism North
Korea did you know that North Korea is
on a campaign to increase tourism they
have a new slogan come for our glorious
sights stay because you saw too much
[Applause]
[Music]
Chipotle in the news
Chipotle okay that's nice are you coming
from there or going there after the
taping yeah
Chipotle is testing deliveries by drone
spokesman for Chipotle said if our food
is going to come flying out of you it
might as well fly into
[Applause]
why did you cheer me leaving
they cheered me leaving it who's here
five minutes I went by yeah you like to
know their name they'll get to beat the
traffic
yeah oh I like konavle let's hope this
ends real to 405 gets bogged down
you